[Musique]
savante dansante cérébrale commercial la
musique électronique est partout mais
comme ça marche
[Musique]
il est ici et là puis là aussi véritable
caméléon le synthétiseur et l'instrument
électronique par excellence aucun sont
du plus simple au plus compliqué ne peut
lui résister c'est quoi le principe
au départ les synthétiseurs l'ailier le
mot synthèse des verts l'idée c'était de
fabriquer le bras sainteté en fait il a
vraiment un ordinateur il envoie une
onde simple à travers un oscillateur ses
notes continuent je voulais faire
écouter
[Musique]
voilà et on le module à travers des
composants et à travers des fonctions
on peut alors régler la hauteur du son
et sa forme
de faire un son plus court très court
aussi avec une attaque lente
grâce à sa déjà on va pouvoir obtenir
des tonnes de son
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
revenons en arrière le synthétiseur plus
fidèle compagnon des musiques électro
dès l'origine
voici son ancêtre fascinante machine qui
permet déjà de modules et un son
électrique
c'est quelqu'un qui a découvert par
hasard qu'on pouvait générer le son en
bricolant une radio bah oui en fait il a
fabriqué un oscillateur l'interface est
très simple qui fait qu' il ya une
antenne quand on entre dans le champ
magnétique de l'antenne on fait varier
la hauteur de l'oscillateur
[Musique]
en s'entêtant à 100 de moustiques et que
autre chose qu'en fait le synthé a
beaucoup évolué depuis bientôt les
instruments électro prennent une forme
plus élaboré et familière celle du
clavier il nous permet aussi la
virtuosité d'un stack hâtif d'été en
fait avec la musique électronique
vous arrivez à combien de combinaisons
et bien nous arriver exactement à 397
combinaison absolument différentes les
unes des autres
le banjo cors de chasse
donc oui je pense que l'idée au départ
c'était d'essayer d'imiter les vrais
instruments qui vont évidemment quand
vous entendez ça imite pas exactement
ont donc ensuite tous ses synthés
analogiques ils ont vite été détournés
de leur fonction initiale
en fait ils devenus des instruments à
part entière et puis tout s'accélère
dans les sixties les orgues électronique
se popularise dans le jazz et le rock
quand soudain débarque le synthétiseur
mourgues une révolution un synthé culte
herbie hancock carl craig ou les beatles
ne vous dirai pas le contraire mais le
premier a popularisé l'engin c'est lui
walter carlos en 68 son album switchback
devient le premier grand succès de
l'histoire des musiques électroniques et
peut-être qu'au xxième siècle comme nous
irons dans des salles de concert nous
aurons sur la selle un homme avec
plusieurs portant sur m qui nous fera
d'écouter de la musique électronique
mais c'est en 76 que l'histoire de cet
instrument trouve ça super star le
français jean michel jarre ou un
ingénieur ou un musicien un musicien
bien sûr mais je pense que je m'adapte
aux astros à mon époque
évidemment si l'une des stars du synthé
qui en tue ma première m'ont touché
parce que j'avais ces disques quand
j'étais tout petit plus de 18 millions
d'albums vendus dans le monde avec lui
le synthé devient incontournable époque
prenant parfois des formes insolites
jusqu'à finir totalement dématérialisé
numérisés dans les logiciels de musique
voilà 50 ans que le synthé est
indispensable aux scènes électroniques
il a mis tout le monde sur la même
longueur d'onde
[Musique]